okay okay it should my psych eval here
we're playing this game called block and
dad okay oh and it's like a tower
building game can I so then we're gonna
do challenge brought its best way to
explain it you know I can't one it's all
about the water I love water water sixty
percent of my body yeah water the less
essential resource of any community
water can be collected from the ground
rivers are rain but often needs to be
transported long distances to be used
that's so true now let's explore the
economy of water now I need to get 250
units of water so I'm [ __ ] their
lives I do this Atari also i was going
on and i got good good okay okay let's
do some [ __ ] water and organic
production production yeah what some
[ __ ] disabled the [ __ ] okay okay I got
this water right here but it needs money
um oh yeah I needs I need that money
baby needs that money so we got a great
I gotta create a input sunita labor and
consumer mmm okay I'm so get that small
apartment going you know baby you know
mm okay God God God God God you gotta
getting a little path for it
and one thing it needs it desperately oh
[ __ ] how's this guy down he oh he has no
electricity or fresh air or [ __ ] sorry
sir sorry I need some trees for this
batch nits entrees I can't get good shut
okay gotcha let's say I let's say here
alg a farm uh huh okay no why isn't this
[ __ ] doing anything hey you got the
water does he had a water no folks a
waterfall oh you're kind of water I move
this mmm yeah let me destroy this and
move this okay the [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] why this [ __ ] not working
there we go okay I need some [ __ ]
trees cuz I people are [ __ ] like they
just want some oxygen and I'm laying low
production data production did okay now
this guy he's got his water good good
this quarter you got no [ __ ] for a
share and that's because this is this is
getting made don't worry don't worry
okay now he's got his fresh air baby now
he's got to rush air um you don't need
some moisture is only know okay we go
now we need to make some labor so lame a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah water time needs
money this is producing money no not
producing any if I got money yep no yeah
yeah get right there baby right there
make a little quarter this [ __ ] got got
got it got it good I love this I love
this now let's make that money right man
let's make that money [ __ ] ain't another
consumer i'm thom hartmann
God and let me make another corridor
right here so it's basically like
supplying tomb animals like economical
pretty nuts now I want everything we
going up Jesus lecture she's going down
right no consumers unlocked the [ __ ] is
that sucks I'm an agent unlocked no I
guess just a person like sure she's gone
down like make another electricity got
again mmm sweet as any gray water
running hey producers gray water no have
you [ __ ] stupid why does she need
labor I Michelle everything I need more
consumers okay so I just waiting for
water is water going out yeah what is
going on production Chad 1 30a 137 but
should we going up against a just make
some more water speed this up great
what's going on with this guy what it
what is necessary here
oh I don't of leisure how do I thought
is leisure it was more trays that's what
they want plenty of air good God god I
love leisure you know now we just gotta
wait and get away from my baby to
continue shopping okay it's getting that
water [ __ ] now taking up too much water
this sucking shut out some 19 you don't
worry don't worry we got this water is
going up real fast babe a real fast what
the hell I'm losing consumers that's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay she says
any more [ __ ] electricity it's a hard
game it don't matter it don't matta you
know you know look at a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] little [ __ ] hello sir nice of
you to join us today I'm just going to
wait for the water to stockpile up very
handsome him very handsome I such a
small [ __ ] block though I see you
have a nice apartment sir amuse her me
sir you're confused he is just walking
back and forth Senor ok ok 242 we almost
did hit babies we almost did it I turned
all that [ __ ] music cuz it was
[ __ ] awful I feel like water minerals
like how much
oh ok gotta always edit guys you know to
move when you talk to her legs all right
yeah